cet homme impôts dont s'acquitte et
jusqu'à présent 85 % des ménages
français la taxe d'habitation les en
2020 elle ne devrait plus être qu'un
souvenir
le gouvernement a annoncé la suppression
progressive de cette taxe cette année
seuls 20% des ménages l'apéro
intégralement
difficile pour l'instant d'évaluer les
conséquences directes sur les finances
des communes les élus locaux n'auront
pas les mêmes la même maîtrise de la
fiscalité locale dans la commune la plus
aisée la réforme ne s'appliquera pas
donc les élus locaux ou encore la
maîtrise de leur fiscalité
dans les autres communes c'est l'état
qui compensera la première année la taxe
sera entièrement compensée par l'état
mais d'après jacques pélissard ancien
président de l'association des maires de
france
un nouvel impôt devrait rapidement être
mis en place les bases mais pas été
rénovée réviser des créations
officielles révisées depuis 1970 avait
48 ans que les bases n'ont pas changé
donc d'un impôt qui avait vieilli donc
c'est à pau effet le réformer
soirée visant des bases mais aucun
gouvernement ne l'a fait sans droit un
autre un autre outil fiscal une réforme
de la fiscalité locale était attendue
depuis plusieurs années reste à savoir
comment elle sera élaboré